foreign
thousands gather in london on the eve of
nakba the day when palestinians
commemorate the trauma of 1948. free
free palestine when more than 700 000
were forcibly expelled or fled their
homeland but now another outrage the
killing of well-known and respected al
jazeera journalist shirin abu akla she
was shot dead by israeli forces while
working clearly labeled as press
and then at her funeral
this
[Applause]
many people have many words for this
attack from the white house podium it
was we regret the intrusion an intrusion
press secretary jensachi would not go on
to condemn the attack and the president
had this to say i don't know all the
detail but i know it has to be
investigated phyllis bennis was not
surprised well there's a very consistent
pattern here the u.s has been for
decades the primary
political economic military strategic
backer
of israel and it's among other things
been committed to preventing any level
of accountability
members of congress have weighed in on
twitter calling it deeply disturbing
unacceptable saying the u.s must condemn
the attack on the funeral and one
congresswoman tweeted after her killing
the u.s must demand an end to israeli
apartheid the german foreign minister
also weighed in is this meda
it's incredibly important to me and
we've made it very clear that her death
is explained in a transparent way and
it's even sadder that the funeral
ceremony could not be held in peace and
dignity to be honest i'm deeply shocked
and the french foreign minister tweeted
as well saying he was shocked and
appalled
condemning the death and demanding a
transparent investigation
the israeli police say they will
investigate given the public comments
from the biden administration it is
unclear how much if any pressure they
will put on israel to follow through to
try and explain
all of this
patty culhane al jazeera washington